qu'est-ce que c'est meilleure question
qu'est-ce qu'il renferme une armée de
fantôme nous avons tous connu des
expériences des rencontres avec
l'inconnu et
l'inexplicable ici nous rachetons au
prix fort vos possessions
possédé alors ça c'est tout à fait
fascinant 40 dollars et c'est à vous je
n'ai jamais rien vu de pareil
jamais
60 New York conna une vague d'attaque de
fantôm SOS fantô vous voulez quoi et
nous nous sommes les
seuls
de bienvenue au nveau CRE de recherche
paranorm traîné vos fantômes on a passé
40 ans à les chasser maintenant on peut
les étudier ah il est trop
chou depuis que vous avez ramené cette
orbe d'étrange phénomène se produisent
les esprits lui obéissent il y a un truc
qui essaie de sortir pas qu'un
seul on pourrait être face à une
véritable armée de
fantôm doté du pouvoir de
tuer par la peur elle-même quoi on peut
mourir de peur ou c'est tendu ça alors
on fait quoi on est SOS fantôme on
défendra on met en ten et on détruit
tout ce qui fait
peur C orbe d'près la prophétie
précipitera la fin de
l'humanité une secondaire
glre
tu la touches pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais